in 1964 President Lyndon Johnson
announced his plans for what he called
the Great Society a sweeping set of
programs that marked the most ambitious
and far-reaching expansion of the
federal government since Franklin
Roosevelt's New Deal Johnson's declared
war on poverty jacked up federal
spending on and control of education and
pushed massive new entitlement programs
including Medicare and Medicaid which
promised to deliver high-quality and
low-cost health care to the nation's
elderly and poor mostly at taxpayer
expense when Republican Richard Nixon
succeeded Democrat LBJ's president after
the 1916 elections he continued and
expanded many of the Great Society
programs despite being from a different
political party but did the Great
Society achieve its goals of eradicating
poverty sheltering the homeless and
helping all citizens participate more
fully in the American dream in a new
history of the Great Society a MIDI
slaves argues that Lyndon Johnson's bold
makeover of the government was a massive
failure despite the good intentions of
its architects and implementers slaves
who is the author of a best-selling
history of the Great Depression and the
chair of the Calvin Coolidge
Presidential Foundation says remembering
the failure of the Great Society is
especially relevant in an election year
when presidential candidates are
promising to spend huge amounts of money
on all sorts of new government programs
i sat down to talk with her about the
origins of the Great Society its failure
and what it all means for 21st century
America a manish lays thanks for talking
to reason
Thank You Nick so let's start what was
the Great Society Lyndon Johnson became
president and the adjective for Lyndon
Johnson is ambitious so he wanted to do
something that would make him look great
greater than perhaps President Kennedy
who preceded him and died tragically
greater than his successor so good
wouldn't do and he and his aides put
together a program they called Great
Society
the impulses though came from sources
beyond Johnson behind him around him
which were the impulses of American
society they young Americans as today
wanted to do something really grand they
didn't even merely constrain their goals
to going to the moon as President
Kennedy had suggested they wanted to
change the society transform its clean
up any errors and make us go from good
to great so you have national ambition
personal presidential ambition and the
third group I'd add our professors
experts who felt that through new
knowledge through the knowledge of
technology the government could get to
great in a way it had not been able to
before we could get to the moon of
domestic policy as well as the moon in
the sky
Johnson promised to cure poverty he
didn't say I will provide a useful
palliative he said I will cure poverty
and to be fair if you look at the
country at the time everyone thought
maybe poverty could be cured everyone
thought poverty could be cured Norman
Podhoretz the great writer said later we
thought this stuff was just the mopping
up action not a big deal if you can win
Europe you can certainly win poverty
Johnson didn't really think too hard
about what he was doing he just thought
we're gonna we're gonna deal with
poverty he created a poverty czar that
was Sargent Shriver the brother-in-law
of late President Kennedy the man who
led the Peace Corps a man with all the
goodwill in the world a very
good-looking man so it was sort of like
Superman Sarge Shriver to be the poverty
czar at the poverty office which was
called the Office of Economic
Opportunity and Johnson thought this is
great but it didn't turn out as they
imagined other big programs included
things like Medicare and Medicaid how
did they sell Medicare well you want to
think it was said of Johnson by Joe
Califano who's a wonderful writer that
he made laws the way other people ate
chocolate chip cookies this is his
strength we've studied this robbery karo
so he said well we'll we'll complete the
health care program that Truman so loved
and was not able to get through Congress
maybe will do more for poor people not
just old people and you know
these things are expensive but will
disappear emember at the time life
expectancy was not where it is today
Johnson himself did not live to his 80s
so these men thought well for a few
years old people can be taken care of
nothing's wrong with that it's a sort of
story of unintended consequences and
these little programs sorta little were
appended to Social Security as
amendments Medicare and Medicaid and
there was no idea this is a story of
unintended consequences that those
programs would become so giant and
effectively begin to dwarf Social
Security itself so though they were
there there was National Public Radio
there was the what we call the long
march through the institution's by the
left we created a lot of institutions
and allowed progressive and left leaners
to begin to to run them so there were
institutions that particularly public
media that that didn't seem I mean
Sesame Street well how can you disagree
with that that didn't seem set to change
or take over our culture but really did
come to shape the culture in ways that
to an extent today seem regrettable in
addition I would add something I never
would have thought of which is they had
a little legal aid office at the Office
of Economic Opportunity with the poverty
czar that sounds nice what's wrong with
that a lady gets beaten up she wants to
get divorced she has no money
she's a mexican-american she may not
even have citizenship she gets a lawyer
funded by the federal government that
legal aid office which wasn't
particularly large at the beginning
became a monster the greatest public
interest law firm in the United States
with a thousand lawyers very soon and
instead of suing rather representing
individual hardship cases what it became
almost instantly an office to change
America through litigation rather than
through legislation so all of a sudden
for example this office from Washington
would be funding an office in California
California rural legal assistance to sue
the governor of California same thing in
others day
or to sue mainly in class actions and
this was not quite I don't imagine what
Lyndon Johnson or maybe even Sargent
Shriver had really thought through it it
was a dynamic that grew on its own let's
litigate ourselves to utopia with the
idea that the private sector was the
milk cow the domestic animal as Kaine
saw but provided the money the
wherewithal for the public sector
experiments and that private sector was
just sort of to the side and to be taken
for granted that's what someone
especially like Johnson or Sarge Shriver
would think well America will always
grow all these because they didn't have
they didn't really have a clear
understanding of private sector of a
kind of capitalist creative destruction
model they just took wealth production
for granted right and and you know
frankly it's easy for us to talk about
creative destruction because we've seen
eBay destroy some kinds of retail we've
seen Amazon destroy other kinds of
retail brutally but arguably
interestingly and maybe for the better
so they hadn't quite seen that they
these people live grew up in the
depression served in the military and
operated in the military-industrial
complex so in the beginning of the book
I described the employees of Fairchild
the camera parts company that also made
microchips wondering if they would ever
have a contract that was not a
government contract well that might not
be possible we're part of the military
account the entire state of California
was dependent on the military they said
that lawmakers would get up on their
hinds like donkeys and Bray when defense
contracts were taken away from their
states because how could California ever
thrive without being all defense that
was the idea and it was a gradual
elimination in the 60s oh yeah we can
make these little chips and we can put
them in things people want at home and
not just refrigerators by the way and
there you know there's a wonderful kind
of enlightenment at Fairchild which of
course became Intel oh wow we can get
contracts from people
we can make things that help the economy
grow without the government everyone at
that time say the men were grown up
maybe they've gone to school in 1948
that's late enough that they would have
learned about planning in economics God
and man at Yale not individual
enterprise which they might have learned
in 1925 and they all fought well
planning and the military industrial
complex are necessary to sustain the
supremacy of the United States in the
bitter cold war right and this is
they're living in a world where
everything was big after you know the
collapse of small-scale capitalism or
the laissez-faire illusion had been
unmasked at the end of the 20s and you
either have big governments like the
United States and certainly the Soviet
Union or big companies like AT&T and IBM
and Xerox that were too big to fail too
big to fail and remember this was also
the time for business friends of Peter
Drucker who saw through it if you want
to look for an intellect the commentator
or business consultant and comments but
it was also the era when we believed in
the conglomerate that the diversified
conglomerate just for the sake of
business and capital really we need
money to slosh around in our company so
there were companies such as ITT which
became absurd because I had so many
unrelated subsidiaries
so imagine bigness for the sake of
business bigness for the sake of itself
at this time in this sudden Epiphany
that may be small might be better and
what's interesting is watching Ronald
Reagan take this in a Californian
because I'm sure at the beginning he
didn't really envision Silicon Valley
Reagan but he did say wow I like this
idea of a creative society that grows
well he will get to him because he's one
of the characters who was kind he kind
of I'll spoil the ending he's kind of
revealed as a major figure in all of
this towards the end of the book but
let's talk about several of the figures
and themes that you come back to again
and again and kind of how they amplify
the themes and your analysis you
mentioned a bit guns and butter this is
something I remember in the early first
half of the 80s taking economics classes
we would hear a lot about the guns and
butter curve or a trade-off between
and butter you actually in in the
beginning of each chapter you you put
the amount of the federal budget that is
devoted to defense guns versus butter
entitlements what is guns and butter and
why is it so important the guns and
butter were to terms were used for
defense and entitlements and the idea as
now is that guns cost so much so much
more than everything else that's a myth
it was even beginning to be a myth then
so what was interesting was everyone
thought we can't afford the Great
Society because of the guns we have to
have the Great Society because of the
guns because we need consolation
distraction and progress at home with
this war not progressing so well abroad
but very quickly in fact within the
timeframe of the book 1971 we're
suddenly spending more on butter than
guns so this idea that all was the
butter made it impossible the federal
government so the one thing we know yeah
the one thing we know is like guns
national defense is a constitutional you
know pre prerequisite whatever of the
federal government it needs to divide to
to supply that and spy 1971 the federal
government was spending more on butter
than on guns that's right and that's a
big change for the United States so if
you look at the defense spending today
relative to the Korean War say World War
two and Vietnam it's very small as the
share of GDP of course this is an
important chart that everyone must look
at because when you look at it you will
see that the whole budget you'll see of
course entitlements are so much more
than guns
don't let anyone mislead you with with
confining terms right always look at the
whole chart so we do spend a lot of
money on guns still but as a share of
the federal budget and a share yes
pruitt-igoe a housing complex it you
begin with you know it's early in the
book and it's very late in the book why
is prude I go what's it a metaphor for
well this book is about the folly of
planning this is a kind of domestic best
and the brightest they were fools the
smart guys who planned Vietnam with
their spreadsheets and their slide rules
and their
they were a kind of fool who failed to
look at reality domestically the best
and the brightest existed two men who
thought they could edit lives to achieve
optimal outcomes so pruitt-igoe was a
housing project in st. Louis very large
one of the largest in the nation and we
thought well we'll house these people
and we'll move them out of their homes
well they live in slums so let's move
them here and they'll all be glad and it
was a rather beautiful complex seems so
at first to the tenants but instantly it
began to have troubles the troubles
partly had to do with the absence of
growth we it was imagined that st. Louis
would fill these towers imagine 22
towers of 11 stories each because of
this it's incredible rate of growth well
saintly we began to stop growing in part
because of its heavy unionization you
can move somewhere else and make make an
auto part or more importantly a part of
a rocket more cheaply and so the housing
project by the sheer arithmetic failed
it didn't have enough tenants who paid
enough rent for for it to succeed and
what's very interesting is in the Great
Society rather than acknowledging the
failure we compounded it by spending
more and more on such housing projects
the idea that big was great and you just
when you failed once you would just add
a few zeros to your old spending and
then this time you would fail I want to
mention that the architect of
pruitt-igoe whose name was Yamazaki by
1965 or so was saying it's a project I
wished I never had built what a stunning
admission from an architect he of course
is better known as the architect of the
World Trade he's the architect of the
World Trade Center my father who knew
him said don't be too hard on him he was
a nice man he was a nice man but the
project was in the international style
the International style turns its bet
the International style turns its back
on commerce its turns its back on the
sense of the human its large in scale
unfriendly
and that aspect the international style
made the gang proliferate in part did
nobody cared it was a tragedy of the
Commons
who would I go nobody cared about it and
everyone trashed it if you know it's a
great way to think about your book as
the domestic policy version of the best
and the brightest Patrick Moynihan comes
in for you know a lot of abuse in this
book talk about Daniel Patrick Moynihan
and you know how he is kind of the
patron saint of the failure of the Great
Society this is very interesting because
we all a lot of us are interested in
Moynihan Moynihan was kind of the wise
fool he was the Jester who sees through
what the king is doing at many points
and a lot of us admire him he's been
compared to Edmund Burke by Greg Reiner
and in his work that is a man devoted to
government who's willing to admit a
mistake and yet persevere there's some
beautiful humility to that this is the
man who later became a senator from New
York
but Moynihan was present and complicit
at at the scene of many errors in the
beginning he writes a federal
architecture manifesto which basically
says we like modern and you can build
modern and you can impose modern on
people what if people don't like modern
right no that doesn't matter it's our
kind of our duty to be modern and so
building such as HUD by Marcel Breuer
very ugly building in Washington loved
by no one Jack Kemp called it all
basement even the upper floors were
permitted in that culture bulldozing was
permitted so there's Moynihan kind of
pushing it along by writing this memo he
also wrote the memo
that gave us the modern public sector
Union and became President Kennedy's
executive order and they were very proud
of this executive order 109 88 because
it didn't give public sector unions the
right to strike so they didn't figure it
had much effect but what it did was
embolden public sector unions to expand
and demand more wages double more wages
you know a little premium because they
weren't going to strike
leading to the budget busting at the
federal level and even at the state
level that public sector unions
represent today so he was there and he
also tried guaranteed income which is
popular now and he tried to write a good
guaranteed income program it's a good
idea Milton Friedman thought part of it
was good well it's easier to give people
money than to condescend to them with
wrongheaded social workers Moynihan said
accurately enough that by funding social
workers we were feeding the horses to
feed the sparrows the real
vulnerabilities in our culture but what
he failed to recognize is the complexity
of giving a lot of people money when you
reach the income level where the money
stops there's a tremendous disincentive
to work because you want to stay in that
band of income low where you get the
money and you there's a tremendous
incentive not to work when you get a
guaranteed income think of a number of
23 year-olds all of us know a certain
payment every month well we'll make
perhaps deter them from taking certain
dislikeable jobs so without sounding
creepy we all see that it's easy to
coast when you get a payment when handed
meanings to succeed in that he didn't
even succeed in that and he went home to
Cambridge Massachusetts but he was wrong
about a lot I want to add that he was
wrong about a lot but he was also right
about one thing which is seeing that the
breakup of the family is destructive and
that the single-parent family is a
challenge and he said so and was the
first person I can remember ever being
canceled for saying so well he did it in
that context of blacks he did it in the
context of black families but his it was
not truly only in the context of black
families because Moynihan himself came
from a family where the father was
absent so he knew firsthand what a
struggle it is for a young man to be
with just a mother and he knew what that
meant economically and the great
uncertainty the sort of a sand beneath
the feet of a family that doesn't have
to
so he you know he knew that illegitimate
see is probably costly and bad for
education so he said all these things
and he was cancelled and so III wouldn't
say he's the demon or even the fool of
the book but he's the he's the human
what was the role of Vietnam in that
both the passage of Great Society
programs as well as their ultimate
failure well in the standard history of
Vietnam was everything I found Vietnam
was surprisingly less important recalled
that when Johnson came into office
Vietnam was not Vietnam it was this
project over there ten thousand fifty
thousand men and then it grew by the end
of Johnson's term which was 68 to 400
500 400 500 thousand very suddenly but
at first not and the Great Society was
much loved even without any Vietnam one
can say well what Johnson and ruther of
the UAW were afraid of was riots in the
cities they had riots and of course
Vietnam did in part force those riots if
you're sending my son to Vietnam I
deserve adequate housing I deserve
police who don't beat me up yes
absolutely but less than I thought
frankly when I went over it so you want
to imagine a stage of actors the
domestic best and the brightest these
geniuses who think they can re-engineer
society in an almost aldous huxley sense
and in the background off stage loud
thunder and rumbles made by contraptions
that's the way it felt and some of the
soldiers came home they were wounded
they were disillusioned but that was
almost into Nixon period it took a while
one thing that Vietnam did do for the
left and the left is in the book was
they took a look at North Vietnam and
they said oh there's socialism I'm gonna
go check it out so there's a chapter
here where Tom Hayden the progressive
activist actually goes to Hanoi looking
for socialism it says well you know
I get it he was completely hoodwinked by
the North Vietnamese and their Soviet
allies oh well but he he saw he got a
sense of unity he said they had a
socialism of the heart in North Vietnam
I I think many of the enemies would
disagree with even those from North
Vietnam later but there he was and he he
drew inspiration from communism and he
saw it as you talk about how the New
Left saw socialism not as a final end
state but kind of as a process almost
the way that libertarians or Hayek ins
will talk about markets as a discovery
process socialism is kind of like a
discovery process well what is you know
I'm not sure Tom Hayden was a socialist
but he was definitely an activist so he
wanted a mass movement how do you get
that well socialism he figured out in
this period is the way because it's
great rallying cry it sounds good and
it's never finished even Karl Marx
himself said it was a process that's the
beauty of it anyone who criticizes
socialism can be rebutted well we're on
the way we're not really there that and
he came back from Vietnam very pleased
with himself because he'd found a modus
operandi for protest how do we know the
Great Society failed and I and I asked
that beyond dollars and cents or I guess
the quickest kind of refutation of the
Great Society is that well you know we
declared war on poverty and the poverty
rate in America since the early 70s has
basically stayed somewhere between 10
and 15% around 12% ergo it's a failure
it hasn't worked or it's like the war on
drugs or you know the war in Afghanistan
it just keeps going but it doesn't
really win or lose but how do we how do
we how do we tone up the costs and the
benefits especially given that things
like Medicare and Medicaid federal aid
to education all of these things are now
almost completely taken for granted how
do we know it failed one way we know is
the 1970s because our government and
then our people and then most
importantly markets realized we were
over
spending and in order to control the
resulting inflation we had to do
something terrible and brutal which is
raise interest rates to 15 or 18 percent
what does that mean when an interest
rate goes up like that
the downside of 18 percent mortgage
interest rates is one fewer bedrooms in
your house maybe two you're a family you
have two children maybe you want three
bedrooms Wow in the 70s with those rates
people couldn't afford houses they
couldn't afford houses in the
neighborhoods they belong to in their
mind and they couldn't afford houses
commensurate to the size of their family
I remember Michael Kinsley the author
said you know that his parents had said
to him this is the nicest house we ever
had our house Ameri is an America great
and he wrote little did my parents know
it would be the nicest house I ever had
because we will always have to diminish
our expectations now because America is
getting smaller and more costly or if
you want to borrow money to start a
business if you borrow it 5% you do have
much more money to fool around to try
out two ideas then when you borrow at
15% only one idea gets tried so it's a
cost it's it's a tax on hope supported
by great society let's talk about Ronald
Reagan because he emerges he he was
governor of California from 67 to 75 he
emerges as a major figure towards the
end of the book his earlier employer at
the beginning of the book General
Electric which is a great kind of
metaphor synecdoche for the the type of
corporation that kind of doesn't quite
make it in the way that it thought it
was going to through the 60s Reagan was
a spokesman for them but as a governor
he was totally against Great Society
because he saw it as the federal
government coming in and taking more and
more control spending more and more
money cause more and more problems at
that local more local government should
be doing but then he later in his
presidency he described saving Social
Security and Medicare through a big tax
hike in the late late 80s as one of the
most significant actions he took as
president he talked about those things
as the final
to the New Deal he was a New Deal
Democrat this was you know he was this
was the most heroic thing he did how do
we how do we make sense of where we're
at kind of as a society or as a
government when things like Medicare
Social Security Medicaid are taking up
about two-thirds of the federal budget
and it's going to get bigger
Reagan is on board with that everybody
seems to be on board with that
where do I mean the Great Society as a
concept seems to have lost but in budget
realities it seems to bring a Reagan and
Reagan's time Reagan would not have
imagined our budget today maybe Reagan
didn't he should have made Friedrich
Hayek that chairman of the Council of
Economic Advisers he didn't so he
imagined that he couldn't leakin tained
these programs that it was political
unreality to assume you could do away
with them and you want to remember he
did constrain welfare both at the state
and the federal level much of the Reagan
spending was defense and he was making a
common sense judgment not all of us
agree with it but Reagan's judgment was
let's spend a little more on defense and
it wasn't more than entitlements Brooke
let's spend a little more on defense and
we'll win the Cold War because we're
less communist than those people over
there are and as long as we're less
communist and closer to freedom than
Russia we will prevail if we only stay
strong so he was in a war he was in the
Cold War and he perceived it that way
nowadays it's easy to say what it was
all inevitable it wouldn't want anyhow
but that was not no no I do you do with
you know now your flash-forward I'm
because Reagan is 30 years ago right so
and now we have you know a budget deal
that has just been signed by Republicans
and Democrats I mean they hate each
other enough where there's an
impeachment process going on but the
we're spending 40.5 trillion dollars we
spend more you know the the most recent
defense budget went up by about a
hundred billion dollars over the past
few years we're spending more on on
welfare and on entitlements etc
you know is what I and I guess this
leads into a final question or topic of
conversation what do we need to remember
most about that Great Society moment for
the current moment that government
failed we need to remember that
government failed both parties one of
the characters is Wilbur Mills well who
is best known for a very early sex game
right right but it shouldn't be because
he was a politician for markets oh I
realize in the middle of it wait the
spending is going to be much greater
than I said I'm concerned mr. president
he said when Johnson hauled him into the
White House and asked him do you know
where you are Wilbur ie you're gonna
agree with me said I'm in mr. president
I know where I am I'm in the wrong place
I'm in the White House I need to get out
sometimes we need to get out all the way
from Washington both parties are to
vainglorious and both parties often fail
in the book Nixon is as bad as Johnson
in some areas as John cope and Hoover
points out Nixon's programs grew faster
than Johnson's his domestic programs
again political trade-off oh I need to
finish the Vietnam War Henry and I need
to do this
therefore Arthur needs to be a good boy
and the rest of us need to expand the
food stamp program so so politicians
will do that but the positive lesson of
the period is told is carried by three
companies GE what became Intel and
Toyota and what it suggests is the
answer to American problems is more
often the private sector than you think
and that the private sector can outgrow
the public sector if you make certain
key reforms so I would argue if you if
you cap Social Security and did
something or other with Medicare and
lower the capital gains rate you'd
probably get enough growth that we
wouldn't be in trouble you right in the
beginning of the book in the
introduction you say once again many
Americans rate socialism as the generous
philosophy but the revolt results of our
socialism were not generous made this
book serve as a cautionary
tell of lovable people who despite
themselves hurt those they loved nothing
is new it has just forgotten what are
your hopes for this book how will you
know if your book has succeeded in kind
of rehearsing a history of recent
history that is almost completely you
know relegated to the to the mists of
antiquity well there's no limit to what
you can achieve if you don't care who
gets the credit so I as Reagan said but
I'm just part of a group of people who
are looking at history in a frank there
are a lot of charts in this book at a
frank and in a frank analytic way and
say look here are the results let's
remember those I'm concerned about
teaching because in high school we don't
get this material in college we don't
get it anymore so our children get less
clarity then even we might have had
having watched some of the history and
having the books to tell the history so
my hope is that the education changes
and I am sure that it won't that change
won't come from the teachers it has to
come from young people who resent being
fed a mono line about how the Great
Society was great the New Deal was great
and everything else is cold mean and
nasty and discriminatory after a while
young people love that that can't be the
only truth and so why my interest is in
seeing them have the opportunity to ask
important questions all right well we're
gonna leave it there we've been talking
with Andy sleighs the author most
recently of Great Society a new history
how many think oh thank you Nick for
reason I'm Nicholas
[Music]
you